This Sunday is Super Bowl LI!
(cheering, applause)
And, as your friends with broken
kneecaps will tell you,
you can place bets
on absolutely everything.
Uh, way more than just
whether or not Bill Belichick
will masturbate through
his hoodie pockets. Uh...
Some of the real prop bets
you can make... uh,
actually make on Super Bowl
Sunday include:
"25 to 1 odds
someone catches fire
during the Lady Gaga
halftime show"
and "45 to 1 odds a fan
throws dildo on the field."
And if you're
wondering how a fan
would get access
to a dildo, let me repeat:
Lady Gaga halftime show.
So, comedians,
the possibilities are endless.
Please come up with as many more
prop bets for the Super Bowl
as you can in 60 seconds,
and begin. Koechner.
Uh, 50 to 1 odds
that Chris Hardwick
spends Super Bowl Sunday
watching reruns
of Star Trek: Next Generation.
Yeah, it's v-very likely.
Very likely.
You don't know-- could be, could
be Doctor Who. You don't know.
Or Stranger Things.
Uh, Aisling.
Uh, ten-to-one odds
that the Russians
already know who won
the Super Bowl.
Yeah, points.
Maz.
One-to-one odds
that Trump will tweet
that his crowds were bigger.
Yeah, points. Aisling.
50-to-one odds
on record-breaking attendance
at A.A. meetings
on Super Bowl Monday.
Yes, points. Maz.
One-to-one odds
that a guy wearing
a Make America Great Again hat
will (bleep) in his pants
when he sees the word
"Patriots."
All right, points. Yeah.